[Music]
three things first of all I made this up
the 11 factors of productive software
organization that is an intentional take
on the 12 factor app which maybe some of
you have heard of that was a guideline
for how to design apps in a pass or
serverless environment that Adam Wiggins
from Heroku did I I'm an alumni of
Heroku so I feel like I'm it's okay to
kind of riff on that originally I
thought I had 12 factors but you know
off-by-one errors they happen so a
little funny story
Adam basically made up those 12 factors
the night before her oak whose first
developer conference they were based on
a lot of great experience but he
basically just threw together a website
you know the 12 factor website putting
together I basically the same thing I
when I was flying in yesterday I
collected my thoughts on on what works
and what doesn't as a softer element org
and it turns out I had about the right
number and so now we've got the 11
factors of productivity all right we'll
talk a little about why serverless in
general and spoiler alert using server
lists is the last factor of being
productive so that's how we tied the two
together and we'll also talk about
what's new in App Engine so why should
you listen to me did I just make all
this stuff up yes I did but this is kind
of sudden places I've worked over my
career the first two were not in cloud
but it was actually PayPal and Amazon
was a super interesting dichotomy I did
an internship at PayPal and PayPal was
still in the monolith software app mode
when I was there things were really
really slow to develop it was very very
painful to get things done it made being
a product manager not very fun it made
me think I wanted to be a product
marketing manager and then I actually
tried that and that wasn't fun either
turns out just wasn't the right place to
do it then I got to Amazon I was
actually working in the
teaming Amazon and but Amazon is in sort
of a lot of widely-publicized papers and
talks had a few years earlier kind of
gone through this transformation where
they took this one big C app that was
all of Amazon I mean this is circa I
don't know two thousand three or four or
five and and they split it into hundreds
of services those even before services
were called micro services and I got to
experience that firsthand I saw that
actually really did work and it really
was beneficial but I wanted to find sort
of the Silicon Valley startup story and
it just so happened that I had a failed
startup where I built a ruby on rails
app and taught myself Ruby and I was
looking for a role and literally on the
CrunchBase one ads Saul job for a p.m.
at this company called Heroku and I
tried it out when I was doing that app
and turned I was one of the first dozen
people there I p.m. to Roku Postgres and
the main Heroku product and I got to see
both internally Heroku sort of some of
our the things we did well on being
really productive as an organization and
things we did really really not well and
I also got to see lots and lots of
customer apps running on Heroku and see
sort of those same you know good and bad
after that it was at docker for a couple
years again sort of got to see both
internally some good practices and bad
practices and also lots of customer good
practices and bad practices and then I
kind of found Google Cloud and then
enjoying that ever since all right so
let's talk about the eleven or twelve
factors of a productive software team
all right number one the YC motto build
something people want it doesn't matter
how productive you are you can make
things lightning-fast
if you build things that are useless
that nobody wants that don't have
product market fit that is the biggest
productivity suck essentially your
productivity is zero if you build things
that nobody actually uses how do you do
that well you know it's actually not too
hard talk to customers before you build
things there's a ton of documentation on
this on the web
talk to people
I would emailing people doesn't count
you might email folks it's it's not the
same medium it is amazingly low
bandwidth versus actually talking to
people I actually like to think of it if
you've ever you seen if have you ever
seen grills in the mist Jane Goodall you
know she was in the jungle observing the
chimpanzees and that's what uh what uh
what what you want to do to figure out
what you what you want whether you're an
enterprise company or consumer company
go to your target audiences sort of
Navin native habitat watch what they do
see the problems they encounter don't
ask them about solutions if you
understand the problems really well then
you can make good solutions for them and
to me that is the key to making things
that people actually want alright so
this is actually something that one of
my colleagues at Amazon said I thought
it's the funniest thing ever I added the
parentheses here premature optimization
is the root of all evil this happens
again and again and again in software
orgs you'll say well we can't do it this
way because that won't scale well who
cares do the do the fast thing that
doesn't scale this way you can test out
if what you're building is actually
useful for people don't solve problems
that you don't have yet because that
means if you don't have the problem yet
that means you don't understand the
problem you might think you're solving a
scaling problem you're gonna hit in six
months but odds are in six months the
actual scaling problems will hit will be
completely different
or if you were right you'll understand
it even better it's sort of a corollary
to that don't plan for scaling more than
10x past where you are even if you're a
hyper growth mode you might be grow a
hyper growth you're growing double-digit
percentages every month in terms of the
usage of your product presumably
software a product you might want to
plan for three months down the line when
you're 50% bigger but don't plan for
when you're 10x bigger because it's it's
really like hard to imagine that just
kind of keep doing those sort of three
months six month things another sort of
great way to avoid premature
optimization that I've seen work in
various forms is Sneaker where you might
have some really really hard problem and
it's going to take a ton of time
to solve it but if you can solve it by
just faking it that works really well
kind of a story there that illustrates
that when I first got to Heroku we had
this dedicated database product there
was a shared database product where you
got one database on a big cluster and we
could spin those up programmatically in
a couple seconds and that's what most
people used but if you wanted to pay the
massive amount of like two hundred
dollars a month you could get this
dedicated database you had a whole
virtual machine to yourself so it turns
out if you went into the interface you
clicked it you get a message that says
your your your database will be
available in 24 hours or less what
really happened was it emailed one of
the engineers at Heroku they wanted the
AWS console they spun up a virtual
machine then they went in and manually
configured your app to use it that
worked great for for the first year
there when we had about you know a
couple hundred of those dedicated
databases pretty soon we were seeing
that it wasn't scaling that's when we
fixed it but if we had said no no no we
need to scale we need to you know plan
for the future the the whole product
would have been out 12 months later and
we wouldn't have learned a whole lot of
other things that we learned so don't
prematurely optimize all right this is
basically the opposite this is how do
you avoid premature optimization it's so
hard to do even if you're just like
writing some code you might be adding
some extra tables to your database or
some extra fields like well I don't need
this now but I'm gonna need it later and
it doesn't cost anything still cost
mental bandwidth still takes time still
has the opportunity to create bugs so a
really great way to avoid premature
optimization is something called a spike
that's where you just you build
something you give yourself some really
short amount of time
one week or two weeks and you tell
yourself or your team we are not going
to use any of the code that we write in
this week we are purely doing this just
a test to make sure that we can build
some software that actually works that
has bear some resemblance to the app we
ultimately want to make what's great is
after you make a spike you can try it
out with customers get their feedback
you also may encounter some of the hard
technical challenges and actually
building the thing you might try to do
something make a dedicate database noise
oh man that's really really really hard
and so you it's a method of discovering
what's hard and what's not and testing
to see if a thing you're gonna build is
actually useful often I've seen teams do
plan to do two or three spikes basically
a week or two each and then go on and
build the actual thing sometimes you'll
discover that your spike is actually
totally good enough to be the actual
product and isn't that awesome you've
got something in two weeks that you can
then actually start deploying all right
another thing I found that like really
productive organizations are generally
shipping really good quality things it
feels great to ship something good if it
was really bad to ship something bad and
so it's and it's really really hard to
do you know I think we sort of have this
prototype in software of Steve Jobs
who's like the the quality tyrant you
know he was sort of famous for berating
people about like you know when the
quality wasn't up to his standards about
how bad a job they were doing so I think
the the trick here is you want to be
ruthless about quality but you never
want but it's never you ever attacked
the person for something that's not high
quality you talk about the the product
that was created
you assume good intentions and you don't
make it personal but you still have a
really really high quality bar and I
think ultimately everybody will feel
really really good about building good
things and that actually really helps
quite a bit for having a proactive org
all right next start with the monolith
microservices is all the rage these days
everybody you know it's you read a ton
about it you'll you'll read blog posts
about you know my microservices
architecture for building the next you
know dog food selling ecommerce site its
III I've seen actually the place I was
at the the team was building some web
services
name names and they were sort of living
in the microservices world so they
decided to make it a micro services app
from day one it had like five or six
different services it was a total mess
basically the this is really just a
corollary to the premature optimization
what what happened in that case was the
team was solving problems they didn't
understand that they thought the micro
services architecture would solve things
really well it actually made everything
harder so it's really simple start off
with a single codebase and then as you
discover what's wrong you split it off
and I think that's actually the next
slide
yep okay so if you do start with the
monolith does that mean you say a
monolith forever no that's what PayPal
did that an eBay did that's what slowed
them down and like let let Amazon
overtake them 15 years ago it's it's
almost hard to remember but like you
know it's like back then like Amazon and
PayPal we're kind of like neck on neck
and neck or Amazon and eBay but so you
don't say a monolith forever you split
out services as you discover your
scaling problems and those scaling
problems can be organizational or they
can be technical for example one pattern
I've seen over and over and over again
is some software's getting some really
really good uptake and it's starting to
hit some performance problems and you
know when you look at it might be like
the database that is causing the
performance problems but it's like one
table is like 95 percent of all the
databases load or 98% at Heroku we had a
group messaging app it was basically the
their whole reason to etre was that you
couldn't send group text messages on
iPhones it's kind of crazy to remember
right so they had this this group
messaging app to solve that work really
really well they started as a monolith
they had a Postgres database and there
was a messages table that was like 98%
of the load on their database and they
pretty quickly got to the point where
they couldn't scale up a single database
larger than what they had they had they
were using the very biggest database out
there
there were a lot of other data stores
besides Postgres that would have been
great for them and that were great for
them so what they did they they split
out a service it was like a messages
service that had a it was backed by a
database that was ideal for that
workload and boom they solved the
problem they moved on another you know
common sort of scaling thing is or the
team I'm a believer in the to pizza rule
you know if you can't like feed your
team on to pizzas
then it might be time to split apart or
you know the can you everybody fit in
the conference room thing you know it's
at you know as the whatever the end law
is of like the number of connections in
a team becomes really really hard once
you get past you know 12 or 15 people to
be a cohesive team so you split across
oh so maybe your scaling problem is
organizational you split out a separate
team and and then they can sort of act
as their own team works really well and
that is I'm gonna skip to number eight
here because that's correlated this so
what you do split out microservices and
teams and this is really really
important you need to make them
technically and organizationally
independent what I mean by that I mean
there is actually a team behind each
service the whole notion of like a micro
service that kind of manages itself is I
think a bit of a fallacy it does happen
but the the pattern I've seen over and
over and over again is you have a micro
service it has its own team really
simple the teams can be as little as one
person although you know you hope they
don't get hit by a bus or they could be
like a full to pizza team but this works
really really well that way that team
can develop its own culture they can
have their own planning process maybe
they decide to do a two-week sprint now
instead of a one-week sprint because
that's what what works best for their
own codebase but they're their own
separate team from a technical
perspective independence means that the
team can deploy their own codebase
indepen
and and this is like this is like a
really easy smell if you've done
microservices wrong if you to do to
deploy your service another team needs
to do a new deployment of their service
and so you need to do this weird
coordinated thing between the two
services you did it wrong if you're not
getting the benefits of a micro service
you just made it harder to deploy new
software so how do you do that you have
a stable version day P is that the
services used to talk to each other
those api's can be HTTP HTTP api's they
could be you know other api's doesn't
matter they could just be going on like
a UNIX socket but there's an API that
thing stay stable then each of the
services can move as fast as they want
around that API occasionally
occasionally you'll have to break that
occasionally you know you realize that
API doesn't have the capabilities that's
why you version it you create a new
version of the API the service that's
consuming that API is still using the
old version once that new version of the
API is out there then it can switch over
on its own schedule to using the the new
version of the API I skipped over number
seven so again there's a team thing I
found that teams work best when they're
either all co-located or all remote
colocation could be a fabulous thing if
if it works for your company you get the
sort of water cooler conversations it's
easy to drop by somebody's desk if you
know if you need some question answered
but you know for a lot of folks that
that's not practical in which case you
you're in remote mode
everybody's remote that means every
meeting has a video conference or a
conference call that they can be on that
means you over-index on writing things
down so that if somebody's in a
different time zone and there was a
meeting they miss they can just read
what happened there are yeah and and and
essentially if you have a hybrid team
where you have like half PF the people
in one location and half the people
remote you basically just need to act
like like everybody's remote and then it
works pretty well but I think this is
one of the really interesting kind of
challenges in terms of like productivity
software
like how do you get remote teams working
better together and I'd love to see some
cool innovation there because right now
it's basically the state of the art that
I've seen is you have a shared Google
Doc on a meeting so everybody can see
that doc you have a video conference and
it's pretty good not quite the same as
everybody being in the same room but
it's still pretty good okay we already
did this one all right what is this one
oh yeah okay so you started off with the
monolith you scale your products getting
traction you started splitting in two
separate micro-services with separate
teams now you've got a new problem this
is this is this is a problem that we
totally had it Heroku that we did wrong
is you you'll have teams that might be
really really productive and they're all
moving in different directions it's like
they're all running in totally different
ways and so that's not really good
either
so you really have to over-index on your
cohesive strategy there's a lot of
different ways to do this I'm a big
believer if you can do it and having
first principles you know Elon Musk is a
big fan of this first principle thing
like what does that mean like I heard
this really cool quote from a friend of
a friend he was talking to somebody who
worked at SpaceX and somebody said what
do you do at SpaceX the way he answered
it is colonizing Mars is essential to
humanity's future existence in order to
do that we need to build a spaceship
powerful enough and economical enough to
get us there and in order to do that we
need to have engines that have a thrust
of this and so I work on the exhaust
valve of the engines in order to make
that happen so there's that first
principle of we need to colonize Mars
and that lets that engineer figure out
like how to build that exhaust valve to
solve the problems that actually matter
another way to do it is you know kind of
what you need when you have a bunch of
different teams is essentially just like
some central strategy czar you know you
typically I had a product or a
co-founder or a CEO
continually says we're doing this and
making sure people align to it you want
to have I think when you have separate
teams you want to have at least you know
half to 70% of time working on projects
that are for the whole organization but
still give them maybe like 20% time to
kind of work on their own projects
whether that's technical debt reduction
or just some features that they think
would be important because they might
have some ground truth from their
interactions with the market or their
software development did they they
realize something's important that's not
important to the whole or but it's
important to they're they're part of it
so give those separate teams like their
their 20% or 40% time to work on
separate independent projects as well
all right
you know it's like they say in in in
politics it's the economy stupid I think
in you know in in organizations it's the
culture it it's sort of trite but it's
really true you want to create a place
that people enjoy working at they enjoy
hanging out with their colleagues that
that will get you through a lot you know
I confession I went to business school
and you do a lot of case studies in
business school and one of my takeaways
one of my meta takeaways when you read
all the KSA's are always about
successful companies and like almost
every successful company in one of these
case studies there's always some really
interesting unique factor in their
culture and that kind of is a it's kind
of like a another way of having that
that that strategy that helps different
teams figure out what they need to do
all right and last but not least you
serve us right is to talk about server
list so I couldn't have left this out
but it really is true and that's we're
gonna talk about next
I think server lists you know and by
server list I don't mean just functions
I mean you know platforms as a service
app based server list things container
based server those things like cloud run
that we launched but serverless really
really really can be a giant
productivity boost you are eliminating
so much of the stuff that you would
normally have to do in running software
it's not it's not for everything but it
for a lot of software it is really great
and so that brings us to the next
section
so why serverless and why App Engine
alright so this is uh obviously and
doing a lot of creative borrowing on my
deck here if you've ever seen Maslow's
hierarchy of needs this is like the sort
of hierarchy of computing you know at
the lowest level you have like the
on-prem you're running your own data
center world I actually even before
PayPal I started off in this role and I
was I was like I was doing a startup and
I rented a rack in a datacenter and I
went down and I racked these physical
servers and then I installed Oracle on
that minute it felt really really cool I
was dealing doing this heavy metal but
it's a lot of work actually you have to
deal with physical security network
hardware or physical servers them going
down you know the internet connectivity
even if you're just like renting out a
data center you and and not most that
stuff isn't differentiated like if
you're differentiating on how you rack
servers but maybe you are I mean if
you're if you're like building like some
crazy infrastructure that is a place to
differentiate I mean I think that's
really where the cloud providers
differentiate is how they operate that
layer or even you know Google outside of
the cloud Google's done a lot of cool
special things and building these really
amazing data centers that let them let
us operate at global scale so you can't
innovate it there but but most companies
don't so the next layer up is cloud and
cloud is really just where you take all
the physical stuff out but you really do
the same things you have virtual
machines you have virtual networks you
deal with cluster management you still
deal with OS updates again like how many
people do they how many people do you
feel that your your companies are are
differentiating based on how well you
update the operating systems on your
virtual machines maybe maybe but I don't
know I doubt it so the next level up is
service and that's where you get rid of
all this other stuff you just focus on
application development in an ideal
world it would be just application
development the code for your app in
reality you've to still monitor for
you know make you know you're gonna run
into some scaling issues eventually and
need to do some Rihanna texture she did
kind of keep track of that but really
you're just focusing on developing your
software your code your business logic
that's where that's where I think 90% of
companies differentiate these days and
then you know Maslow's hierarchy of
needs the hey once you've met all that
all the needs like eating and sleeping
and all those other things you have
self-actualization and so I think that's
you know if you do all these things you
can self actualize and actually build
great products which is hopefully what
we all want to do and I think you as you
go up the stack obviously you get more
productivity the less other stuff you
have to do the more you focus on the
stuff that matters all right so that's
why service all right now we're gonna
kind of shift into the other part of the
talk I kind of mentioned that you know
there's kind of two talks and one here
which is what's new in app engine how
many folks are app engine current app
engine users have you guys tried out the
second gen runtimes anyone okay
so that so this this is the big thing
that's new we've been we've been
releasing what we've been calling the
second-generation
app engine runtimes since if I stand out
of the light can you guys still see me
it's like really blaring over there yeah
good so we were reasonably what we
called second-generation runtimes and I
wish I had all this on a slide I'm just
going to talk through a little bit App
Engine of 10 years ago was it actually
for those who don't know it predated
Google cloud yeah yes question
thumbs up it's good yeah yeah it is good
yeah a pretty cool cloud the reason it
it's not called Google cloud app engine
is because there was no Google cloud
when an app engine existed it's actually
I think it's one of the only products in
Google cloud that is usually referred to
as Google X it's Google App Engine is
the common moniker for it almost
everything else is cloud cloud span or a
cloud memory store cloud compute engine
so yeah and it was this all-in-one
product because there's no rest of the
cloud you got everything all together
you had datastore for storing your data
you had memcache G which was a Google
proprietary variant of
memcache you had a search API you had a
users API for managing your users that
anyone using the users API yeah it's
great it's great but I mean if you were
building an app today so it's for those
who don't know the users API literally
you can use an API that will manage your
user data like so you don't need to have
like a user's table in your app right
but you would never build an app that
way if you're building from scratch you
would just have a user's table you
there's a ton of libraries in every
language that help you manage users and
that's how you do it
but you know that's that that was what
was built so that there were bunch of
other restrictions because and this
isn't widely publicized but because it
sort of predated Google Cloud Google App
Engine was and still does it runs in the
same Borg cluster as the rest of like
Google proper it's running right
alongside of search and ads and all
those other products that make the the
real money for Google and so those
happens and as a result was super
lockdown you didn't even have direct
network access you could not just call
out to to a network address so you had
to use this API called URL fetch and
you'd call the URL fetch API and then
some other service would go go go fetch
what you were looking for so just as
kind of a very funky funky environment
so what we've done on the second
generation runtime so we start releasing
last year is we we've basically defunct
it we took out those proprietary API is
there's no users API you just do the
user yourself you've direct network
access so you know and you know most you
know API client libraries will work for
you and and we've been we the first
language on those on the secretary at
times was node it's actually been
getting great uptake node was not
available on App Engine standard prior
to that and now we have all these
languages a couple of these are we're
out before a lot of them we just
announced at
the conference so Google Cloud has seven
languages that we support this has we
now have six out of the seven on the
second generation runtimes a couple of
user alpha it's really easy if you want
to go into the alpha you can just ping
me it's yeah we basically let everybody
in even though it's officially a private
alpha yeah and you maybe you've heard
about cloud run that's one that was the
big service announcement at the
conference
these at pensions second edition
runtimes are running on the same
infrastructure as called run they're
running actually in docker containers
and bass and Cod run is from a
simplified point of view it's just
removing the sort of app engine code
building layer and exposing the
containers directly to you so I've got
all these now these are modern languages
you should try them out and you this is
a you heard it here first we are on
those second-generation runtimes we are
doubling the memory that you get right
now the the smallest instance class you
get 128 Meg's of RAM that hasn't changed
in a while and what we're seeing is
actually that most apps even really
simple ones don't fit in 128 Meg's
anymore
so all the second return times are going
to get double the RAM will be shipping
that this quarter I'm hoping I'm
crossing my fingers that it's going to
happen in the next six weeks but
officially sometime this quarter
there'd be no price change you'll get
double the memory on second gesture and
runtimes so surprise it's gonna be
really fun like I said before and this
is really really important the second
runtimes enable open network access why
is that important well Google clouds got
some cool stuff
there's cloud storage for storing your
blobs that wasn't available on the old
app engines available on the new one
there's cloud spanner where you can
build a you can have a database that's
like on multiple continents on the last
session I demoed an app that was running
on multiple continents using spanner
but without open network access you
couldn't actually use any of those api's
so now open network access you can just
use the Google cloud client library and
access those Google API is directly but
like I said and this is where sort of
the products a little complicated
because App Engine is still running in
that main Google Borg cluster it it
actually is not on the same network as
the virtual machines that you might spin
up in Google cloud proper and a lot of
the products in Google cloud like
notably cloud memory store are based on
the virtual machines
so besides network access there's a
really really big thing this that we
announced here is VPC connect so Google
Cloud has V pcs I'm not a networking guy
network to me is like magic pixie dust
but what's cool is this is it really is
magic it works so this is a really cool
town in France it the road to it gets
under water on very high tides it's just
like a little jewel box right town so
this is sort of app engine before VPC
connect it was just this little island
really great if you had what you want on
the island but with VPC connect
we've got a bridge from the island to
the mainland it's kind of a cute little
analogy but the important thing here is
you can have your VMs and Google cloud
you can have the number one feature
that's been asked for on the second
engine runtimes has been a caching
service memcache or Redis so you can
spin up your reticence stints and later
on when it's available a memcache
instance it's an it's in a V PC you
create a V PC connector an app engine
and you just address it on its internal
10 dot dot 0 dot whatever address and it
works and actually that was so far the
folks have been using the second engine
runtimes it's been the number one
requested feature is actually is just
having a cache and this delivers that
[Music]